hollow knight fans react to some new
silk song speculation and jeff keeley
reveals even more about summer game fest
jeff keeley organizer and host of summer
game fest live has advised fans to
manage their expectations for this
week's event during a recent twitter
spaces discussion keely confirmed the
show will have a couple new game
announcements but it will be more
focused on games that have already been
announced keeley said people can expect
to see games like the kalista protocol
call of duty modern warfare 2 gotham
knights and cuphead the delicious lions
course throughout the event while dwayne
the rock johnson will also be there for
some sort of announcement keeley added
quote this is not the game awards we've
got a lot of good stuff to show you but
buyer beware of some of the crazy rumors
i'm seeing out there in terms of things
people can expect to get announced and
speaking of rumors and speculation
hollow knight fans have their fingers
crossed tight following a couple tweets
earlier today it all began when jeff
keeley tweeted quote there's nothing
like the feeling of seeing a good world
premiere arrive in your inbox matthew
griffin a member of team cherry's
marketing and publishing team replied to
the tweet saying quote i approve of the
ts and those five words plus one
emoticon have galvanized those who have
been waiting for more hollow knight
reactions to the tweet have been varied
from fans pleading with griffin for this
to be true to others who are
anticipating having their happiness
destroyed we actually asked jeff keely
about hollow knight in our 20 questions
video
so i'll link that below in the
description so you can watch it when
this video is done summer game fest live
takes place thursday june 9th starting
at 11 a.m pacific 2 p.m eastern and
we'll be covering the whole event so
make sure you tune in another big event
that we'll be covering is the xbox and
bethesda showcase on june 12th and now
microsoft has announced that there will
be an extended showcase a few days later
promising even more reveals in a blog
post microsoft said that the xbox
showcase extended will take place
tuesday june 14th starting at 10 a.m
pacific 1 p.m eastern and this is
looking to be a lengthy one as well
clocking in at around 90 minutes which
is about the same duration as the main
xbox the showcase microsoft also hosted
an extended showcase last year in 2021
that featured news about halo hellblade
and more however there is no word yet on
what games may show up at this year's
extended event it seems we'll know more
following the main xbox showcase on june
12th so we'll make sure to keep you
updated and while we're on the subject
of xbox a goldeneye 007 remaster looks
like it may be coming sooner rather than
later vgc first reported that wario 64
who frequently tweets video game sales
and bargains spotted achievements for
goldeneye 007 on xbox servers this past
sunday this is not the first time that a
potential goldeneye remasters
achievements have leaked back in january
they leaked the exact same achievements
which can still be found on true
achievements considering the timing of
this leak and its proximity to the xbox
showcase on june 12th that goldeneye
double 07 remaster may be releasing even
sooner than we think however don't get
your hopes up too high until we have
that formal announcement elsewhere in
the world of james bond games io
interactive the developer behind the
hitman games has been steadily working
on its own bond game which will feature
a completely original story for the
world's most famous super spy now let's
pretend you're a super spy lay out the
plan for me how are you extracting
information about silk song before
summer game fest get creative don't make
it violent or weird though and i'll see
you in the next one
[Music]